[Aplausos]
los veteranos dejaron la paz el
ministerio de gobernación anunció la
captura de varios de ellos y la
cancelación de licencia de varias
asociaciones de militares retirados que
atacaron las instalaciones del congreso
de guatemala para presionar la
aprobación de una ley con las que cada
uno recibiría unos 15 mil dólares por
haber prestado su servicio durante el
conflicto armado interno de momento
tenemos
dos personas que actividades dos
personas que están en custodia del
hospital que también van a ser
capturadas y hay dos personas que
tenemos en este momento en seguimiento
de capturar ya que fueron los que
participaron en la quema de los
vehículos del congreso de la república
y dentro de eso lamentamos también que
hay cinco agentes policiales
los cuales fueron heridos la violencia
estalló luego de que los veteranos
fueran citados en el congreso para
conocer el avance de la ley pero
argumentaron que los diputados no los
atendieron lo que provocó su ira
ingresaron al estacionamiento y quemaron
algunos vehículos
exigimos a las autoridades que
intervengan y se restaure la
tranquilidad en la población e
investiguen los actos de vandalismo
acontecidos de forma ilegal instalando
terror y dañando bienes del estado y los
alrededores del congreso de la república
la compensación económica de los
veteranos fue una de las promesas de
campaña del presidente alejandro
giammatei advirtieron que los hechos son
sólo una muestra de nuevas acciones que
realizarán hasta que la promesa se
convierta en ley